[Music]
it was a big night for pink and her
family at the MTV Video Music Awards and
her six-year-old daughter Willow heart
managed to adorably steal the show what
does it mean to have her here seeing you
get this award dream thing having my
six-year-old girl in a three-piece suit
tonight and my husband looking as dapper
as ever it's just a fun night willow
turned heads on the red carpet 20 with
her famous parents in a three-piece
polka dot suit how proud of your mommy
are you ET spoke to Pink's mini-me who
cutely praised her mom before she was
honored with the prestigious Vanguard
Award during the singers acceptance
speech she returned the love to her
little girl and willows reaction was
priceless you my darling girl are
beautiful and I love you thank you MTV
willow melted our hearts even more when
she knew the words to Peaks hit song
what about us
[Music]
and it doesn't get much cuter than this
mother-daughter exchange where willow
gave her mom a high five mid performance
[Music]